matteo like i wish i had a trophy to
give you some that's what i started to
say i started to say to you at the end
of the show i was like you're so funny
but i kept wanting to be like i know you
know like and it's not just because
you're a confident guy but i was like
you don't need me to say it but like
you're like a treasure like what the
[__] is going on i'm the least funny of
my group of friends my friend bob and
nick are the funniest i think nicholas
nick like high school bob the drag queen
and my friend nick smith nick smith
smith i'll call nick he's he's about six
foot four 120 pounds and only wears
women's blouses and sounds exactly like
squidward and i'll call him and i'll be
like hey nick what are you doing i'm
watching a murder mystery and if you
call me again you'll be the next mystery
click
that's nice i gotta say i don't want to
like again with chris red how transfixed
i was
he said with his blackness i don't want
to be that way for your gayness but i do
tend to be obsessed with people like
that like i know a couple gay guys that
have like high what do we call it tude
sure just you know like strong personas
yes maybe they're not even personal
that's always in like whenever i get
like an audition like they'll have the
character descriptions like knows
themselves confident sassy i'm like just
say [__] we don't have to do all this
sort of you could tell like a a straight
person wrote it because you can hear the
fear and the description like confident
in themselves knows themselves love
themselves sassy i'm like right sassy
then you read the scripts it's like
what's the stitch i'm like i'm out
that's all i'll never make it as an
actor i
strongly disagree do you uh i i feel
like
you're
are gonna are you doing it sure well i
right now this is the past you see all
the gears i was like what if he's done
something i haven't seen no no i've done
nothing i've i've tried so hard to like
before october or like last september i
tried so hard to like play the game in
the industry of like i'll audition all
right this thing it's just a resounding
no from everyone and then andrew i can't
believe it it's true and andrew schultz
pulled me aside and literally saved my
career he was like put just focus on one
thing you're really good at stand up
just focus on stand up ignore everything
else and do reels on instagram i'll
teach you how to do them and he like
literally taught me like do them this
way here's how they should look blah
blah blah and it was like a great
thing well my whole life has changed
from him yeah i went literally it went
from i'm a great actor by the way he's
he's a great audition for crashing for a
part and i really wanted him for it but
i i didn't get to you know choose
he he i mean i always think and results
literally changed my life like me my
well i i was like okay i started doing
it all of a sudden i saw my following
like explode i went from like 200 000
followers so now i'm almost at 600 000
in like less than a year and my tour is
selling out i'm doing theaters now and
it's like literally from andrew schultz
being like just focus on this one thing
i'm like okay i'll do it yeah and i
didn't it was it was so it's so strange
like my agent was like we sold out this
theater in chicago twice the park west
and my agent who i love he was he was
like i'm not trying to be insulting but
let's check and see if there's some kind
of mechanical error like we just
couldn't believe
because i couldn't sell tickets i would
everyone was saying no i was trying to
sell a netflix special no hbo special
they were like nope like everyone was
like no and i was like i so i just
everything you see online like me and my
stupid yellow shirt was the hour that i
was trying to sell and everyone said it
wasn't good enough and then i cut it up
and just put it online and then now i'm
like okay now i'm doing theaters like
i guess i like it it was kind of a
validation being like for so long i
thought i wasn't funny or good and i was
just watching so many people like
surpass me like should i be acting
should i be writing a script what should
i be doing and then andrew was like do
the thing you wanted to do originally
yeah do stand up so now i'm doing just
i'm like okay stand up i'm like on the
stand-up train like going full speed
ahead i'm having
so much fun wow and and getting less
distracted and yeah now i don't care
about anything i'm like okay if i i like
now i'm writing a show with my friend
jared that we're gonna try and sell but
we'll see and but it's like right now
i'm really just focusing on like all
right the next thing i wanna do is like
sell an hour let's see if i can get
there
and because i have a whole new hour that
i'm really proud of and
yeah i'm just like stand up focused
that's great i just don't know how to do
all that stuff so andrew like changed my
life what like acting and stuff i don't
know like selling everyone's like i
don't understand how people get hours
it's like i feel like that's that like
wizard hat and harry potter where they
just like put it on your head and
someone's like
hbo oh my god i love you you did exactly
peacock hbo
netflix
[__] you
youtube youtube is smart like joel is
and yeah
norman oh
hey
they
they're so smart they're like putting
their stuff on youtube it's amazing
like that's not normal mark is a great
joke writer oh my god phenomenal joke
writer i've always mark used to open for
me believe it or not like 10 15 years
ago once or twice but
you can't be doing this that much yeah
we all have our thing i'm sure you know
i hope mine's not as obvious as oh i
don't know i'm sure mine's just
something really gay
just my general existence
[Music]